so like I said somehow controversially
you've been an uh proponent of Peace on
on Twitter on X yeah so let me ask you
about the wars going on today and to see
what the path to peace could be how do
you hope the current war in Israel and
Gaza comes to an end uh what path do you
see that can minimize human suffering in
the long term in that part of the world
well I think that that part of the world
is is definitely like if you look up the
there is no easy answer in the
dictionary it'll be that like the
picture of uh the Middle East um in
Israel especially so there is no easy
answer
um what my this strictly my opinion of
you know is that
uh the the goal of Hamas was to provoke
an overreaction from Israel um they
obviously did not expect to uh you know
have a military Victory um but they they
they expect they really wanted
to commit the worst atrocities that they
could in order to provoke the the most
aggressive response possible from Israel
um and then leverage that aggressive
response to um rally Muslims worldwide
uh for the cause of Gaza and palestin
which they have succeeded in
doing um so the the the the
counterintuitive thing here I think that
the the thing that I think should be
done even though it is very difficult uh
is that um I I would recommend that
Israel engage in the most cons
conspicuous acts of kindness possible
every everything that is the actual
thing that would thwart the goal ofas so
in some sense the degree that makes
sense in geopolitics turn the other
cheek implemented it's not exactly turn
the other cheek um because I do think
that there's
um you know I think it is appropriate
for Israel
to find the Hamas members and you know
um either either kill them or
incarcerate them um like something
something has to be done because they're
just going to keep keep keep coming
otherwise um
but uh in addition to that they need to
do whatever they can um there's some
talk of say ing for example a Mobile
hospital I'd recommend doing that
um just making sure that uh you know
there's food water uh medical
Necessities
um and and just be over the top about it
and be very transparent so it's so the
can't people can't claim it's a trick
like just put wave cam on the thing you
know all
24/7 deploy acts of
kindness yeah conspicuous acts of
kindness that that with that are
unequivocal meaning they can't be
somehow because humas will then their
response will be oh it's a trick
therefore you have to counter how how is
it not a
trick this ultimately fights the broader
force of hatred in the in the region yes
and I'm not sure who said it to an
apocryphal saying but an eye for the for
an eye makes everyone blind now now that
neck of the woods they really
believe in the whole ey for ey thing
um but I me you really have if if you're
not going to just
outright commit genocide like against an
entire people which obviously would not
be acceptable to to to really shouldn't
be acceptable to anyone um then you
you're going to leave basically a lot of
people alive who subsequently you know
hate Israel so really the question is
like how for for every Hamas member that
you kill how many did you create mhm and
if you create more than you killed
you've not succeeded that's the you know
the real situation there um and it's
safe to say that if you know
um if you know if you kill somebody's
child in
Gaza you you you've made at least a few
uh homas members who will die
just just to kill an
Israeli that's the situation
so but but I mean this is one of the
most contentious subjects one could
possibly discuss but but I I think if if
the if the goal ultimate is some sort of
long-term peace one has to be look at
this from standpoint of over time are
there more or fewer um terrorists being
created